where i sit on the plane is where i
could see uh
you know the engine and everything uh i
happened to be being a bad kid and uh
kind of getting up and grabbing
something on my back while we was taking
off
um and you know i just remember walking
back to my seat
and as i got to my seat i just hear a
loud bang
and me and mike looked at each other and
he was like oh those
that was those are the birds i guess
mike's seeing the birds passing through
the window
and then seeing it as it was happening
so all i heard was a bang
and then i turned and look out the
window and see the whole like engine
shaking and everything
and then you see everybody in the back
kind of like
you know reacting to what's going on
and you know a lot of people in the back
that were sitting like
you know behind the engine and stuff
like that
they seen a burst of flames so
immediately they they're probably
thinking like the plane is fully caught
on fire
and i see everybody kind of reacting
towards that um
and then we just recalling that whole
situation was pretty crazy the whole
plane just started shaking
it was just uh it's definitely uh
something that you know experience that
i'm happy that you know we were able to
tell
because like i said a lot of us really
uh
you know came to like a point
at least 30 seconds in that flies
everybody came to the point where it was
like man this might be
this might be over for us and um you
know it's sad to say that and you know i
don't play with
death or any anything like that um
and uh it's just something that you know
we got to push through and come together
and uh
you know keep going well for the group
of us you know i think it was me jc
joe and me a favor like we're all kind
of right there
in between both wings of the plane and
uh
and all of a sudden it felt like there
was an explosion
uh like literally that's what it sounded
like for most people on the plane like
something
like we hit something big and the plane
immediately started to
bounce and then just started tilting to
the left and people in the back of the
plane said they saw
flames and you know people in the front
obviously didn't know what was going on
and
like immediately like altitude started
to drop a little bit and
and we started like like looking down
and like wondering what what just
happened and
like nobody knows everybody's just quiet
you know we're just in shock and
and it took uh you know the pilots you
know probably five to ten minutes
probably about ten minutes to go through
everything and get you know go through
their checks and
kind of get back to us and let us know
what was going on because it was obvious
that
uh something was really wrong with the
plane it felt like the plane was like
breaking apart in midair so
for us we you know for like i said for
five ten minutes you know it felt like
just just complete helplessness so um